su médico puede recomendar una
radioterapia de intensidad modulada un
procedimiento que trata ciertas formas
de cáncer para matar las células
cancerígenas o controlar su crecimiento
las células del cuerpo crecen y se
dividen como parte del ciclo celular
normal el núcleo de la célula controla
este proceso
dentro de cada núcleo un material
genético llamado adn contiene las
instrucciones para dirigir este proceso
a veces el adn de la célula se daña
normalmente el adn responde al repararse
por sí misma u ordena a la célula a
morir
sin embargo en el cáncer las partes del
adn de la célula que dirigen la división
de las células se dañan
cuando estas secciones quedan dañadas el
adn no puede repararse
en su lugar el adn sin preparar causa
que la célula crezca y se divida sin
control en más células dañadas llamadas
células cancerígenas
un tumor se forma mientras las células
cancerígenas se multiplican y se
dispersan como las células normales la
radiación mata a las células
cancerígenas al infligir un gran daño a
su adn
el tumor se encoge mientras las células
dejan de dividirse y mueren
si el tumor está en su cabeza su
terapeuta de radiación puede hacer un
marco de malla o colocarle una máscara
que lo mantendrá ubicado correctamente
durante la rm o tendrá tatuajes pequeños
permanentes para ayudar a alinear la rm
y luego su terapeuta era una tc de su
cabeza para tener una imagen detallada
de su tumor y sus bordes
su médico usará los resultados para
especificar la forma tridimensional de
su tumor y tejidos vitales cercanos
la forma tamaño tipo y ubicación del
tumor ayuda al médico a determinar
cuánto debe ajustarse el haz de la rm
para darle al tumor y evitar dañar el
tejido sano
durante su procedimiento un acelerador
lineal médico arrojará un as de rayos-x
a su tumor
una computadora dentro del acelerador
ajustará el haz con un dispositivo
llamado colimador
el colimador ajustará o modular a la
intensidad dirección y forma de las de
radiación
esta característica permite que dosis
altas de radiación sean enviadas al
tumor mientras evitan dañar el tejido
saludable circundante
usted puede recibir muchos tratamientos
de radiación durante días o semanas esto
permite que su cuerpo se recupere entre
los tratamientos y más de tantas células
cancerígenas como sea posible
los efectos secundarios son normalmente
suaves y ocurren solo en el área de
tratamiento los efectos secundarios
comunes incluyen irritación cutánea
localizada pérdida de cabello localizada
o inflamación e hinchazón cerca de la
ubicación del tumor